there are democrats right now
it's not just aoc a couple years ago
it's not just ilhan omar it's not just
these clowns gretchen whitmer et cetera
there are democrats running right now
who are running on the idea still of
defunding the police still of putting
more criminals out in the street and
much more so now here's john fetterman
or federer woman as he calls himself
again he is the
democrat running for senate in
pennsylvania against dr oz and he wants
to put inmates back out on the street
because that's what people care most
about right now we have a catastrophic
bottleneck in our prisons of over 5 000
men and women condemned to die in prison
and many of them i believe personally
are deserving of a second chance if you
had a magic wand and you could wave it
and fix one thing
what would it be
life without parole in pennsylvania we
could save billions in revenue long term
we could save thousands of lives and and
not make anyone less safe and also
expunge as many permanent records of
people that have been living their best
lives and have been paying well beyond
when they should have for a charge that
they caught you know 10 15 20 years ago
okay because you guys know i'm fair and
i like given the devil is due first off
i will say that there are probably ways
that we could look at the prison system
and prison reform and figure out ways to
get some people back out on the street
who are non-violent offenders maybe drug
offenders have been there for a long
time or of a certain age etc etc there
are some things we can do about that by
the way there was a guy
who was that guy he was president with
the crazy hair a couple years ago trump
who thank you connor put it
that's good they put it on the
teleprompter for me um
trump yeah trump did prison reform and
nobody really gave him any credit for
that if you want more on that you can
watch my interview from earlier in the
week and last week with jared kushner
anyway uh fetterman i'll give him credit
partly right so you got some of that
okay you want to get these people out
what's interesting though is the focus
on that in that fox interview which was
the second part of what we just showed
you the interview is saying what's one
thing that you're really focused on
right now he could have answered
anything well you know we do have crazy
crime and right he's in running in
pennsylvania philadelphia is a nightmare
right now he could talk about all the
businesses that were destroyed their
focus on these things is what the
problem is right this guy if you had a
magic wand what would you do man and his
focus is well i'd like to just get more
criminals out on the street this is a
problem